devising to be my second
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to episode
40 yes is pretty good one we got today
for zero
been a while since we've done long about
serial killers so yeah we have actually
been thinking that we we've done like a
bunch of paranormal ones the last three
weeks which is cool but I wanted to kind
of do a true-crime one because we had
done one and so long yeah this this
one's off your new book and yes one of
the cases from yeah and then you guys if
you if you like paranormal and stuff
like that you know my new book the
unseen hand which is which is out now is
a compilation but the next book I'm
working on is also a compilation but
it's going to be a compilation of
unsolved murders but kind of the
creepiest unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's actually going to be three
volumes which I didn't really plan at
the beginning but I found so much stuff
I wanted to write about this it was
about three books worth so I'm going to
be so I'm working on the first volume
right now and this case is actually in
there and let's before we get into that
about the Atlanta Ripper
yeah that's what this new a novella be
Atlanta Ripper and I'll kind of get into
it in a little bit in a little bit but
before we do that let's do our regular
do our regular thing and give our shout
out to project Entertainment Network
yeah whoo god that's blowing up yeah
like with this you guys I don't even
know why this happened but we are audio
downloads of the audio podcast more than
tripled yes like 11,000 downloads now
yeah in one month and one month it
really it all happened in about two
weeks yeah because yeah because it's not
like this month doesn't even over yet
had some does he had a low-range show
yeah it seemed like our Drupal wisdom
yeah there was like a huge spike like
after that is this looking forward I had
no idea like so many people were into ed
lorraine warren and then they went back
and started from the very
our very first show also skyrocketed
episode 1 yeah the one he leave out the
Edit and designing we can sit there a
lot about 400 500 people slowly going
through from the first episode on I go
back and look going back and listening
to them in order it's a trip so that's
pretty rad it's like yeah that's I
really appreciate all of our new
listeners well in our old buzzers do
they appreciate all our listeners yes
looks like someone spilled over onto the
podcast also in a podcast are the
YouTube show you give Shia but ok unseen
hand flying off the shelf the audio book
is selling some like crazy we're
tracking that and some of them are
people from our podcast I think but I
think most of them are just people from
members are audible yeah
just regular members it doesn't see I'm
like amazed at how many people actually
bought that in audiobook yeah it's Kayla
may I know this money is like the e-book
of it it's just kind of flat yeah it
goes like that I think I mentioned this
on another episode but I can't tell you
never can tell what format something's
going to do wrong well on maybe the
unseen hand maybe because it's long I
don't know and there aren't a lot of
members on my what review there's only
one one audiobook there's only one a
book review that's probably what it is
yeah most of the reviews are falling on
to the audio book page yeah audio and
nothing is where is that it's it's so
well and just regular regular print hard
copy yeah weird it is very strange
well okay well yeah yeah we'll see how
it goes and like I said if one of you if
you guys have read it and liked it and
stuff like that then you know if you
want to leave a review on Amazon that
would be yeah if you've read it on if
you read it on eBook please leave a
review yeah it does it really does help
good really they don't start selling
until there's at least one room in there
one of you actually they started selling
the other one start of summer one day
like a good day yeah
when you're got six reviews and they
start so they start selling yeah but
let's see what else was okay I mentioned
project Entertainment Network oh I also
want to mention and I think I mentioned
this maybe not a last week shipment on
the one before that
um we're going to do we're going to
start doing like a more like a shorter
version of our show they're going to
clock in this yeah like not of not
aversion of the show there won't be a
voiceover and stuff but we're doing more
like a kind of a cool lead design
more list-based yes it was kind like a
list channel yeah time again it's going
to be really cool and I've seen I've
seen when Jenny's done so far it's one
of the best-looking ones out there I
think it is the best-looking one out
there could be pretty neat well thank
you yeah and so you know but it'll have
the same kind of you know they'll be
paranormal self true crime stuff just
you know general weird [ __ ] like we
usually do on the show and then you know
I'm I'm working hard on it to make it
look pretty so I'm not entirely sure
when you know when the words because I'm
going to put up a bunch of them at once
yeah it probably averaged about five to
ten minutes each one yeah I'm gonna try
and keep them under ten minutes because
you know I know it's a lot to ask for
people to sit and listen to us right
listen us yep for an hour there's a
whole market for four channels it don't
do anything but just little little
videos that are under ten Mitch so
that's one of the things that we're
doing we're going to use that kind of
promote the show and some of the J's
books and things like that but it's
gonna be legit you guys all like it yes
yeah I'm gonna work really hard to make
it look night you a DD youngsters will
love it yeah back in my day we had this
thing okay so all yeah okay so uh yeah I
think that's pretty much this gives me a
lesson
okay now this this case has fascinated
me since I heard about it and I didn't
hear about it that long ago and the
thing that I find the most interesting
about it is how forgotten it is yes
we're safe and here's the thing I've
been working on like I said my new true
crime book which is going to be three
volumes but the first volume should be
out before the end of this year
hopefully by the end of October that's
what I'm shooting for it's called the
faceless villain should be should be a
pretty quick you're almost halfway
through it yeah yeah I'm almost halfway
through this so basically this first
volume is going to be you know 1900 and
1960 is the first is the first one yeah
it's going to be a big one probably
another 354 pages yeah so it's weird
because I initially wrote and I and I
wrote them in you know the cases I write
them in like chronological order like
each year like whatever cases happened
that year and it's weird because I have
written the 1911 chapter and that case
was what that was the case of LC career
Beck she was a little girl in a Chicago
that man
and was found dead later on and they
never discovered who killed her but
while I was researching something else
later on I came across the case of the
Atlanta Ripper and I said why did I
never hear about this yeah because I
mean I'll get into why probably most
people never heard of it later on
because there are some reasons but um
basically I mean this guy was like the
American Jack the Ripper and they think
I mean by the most conservative estimate
he killed at least eight women yeah but
it was probably more like 20 there some
about this story kind of remind you of
the movie Candyman yeah it is kind of
like that idea this was done by one of
the witnesses said the use every bolt
all black out the long coat big ol print
hat why prime time my interns had yeah
it's kind of a cool kind of cool story
the reason why I think that it's kind of
a forgotten case largely and even when I
was doing a lot of research for the book
and research for the podcast and stuff
like that there's really not a lot of
information on it and the reason for
that is because it happened in Atlanta
Georgia in the early part of the 20th
century and all of the victims were
black or mixed race women and according
to witnesses they think the killer was
probably black as well which you know
serial killers like I said just like
they said in salads in the land serial
killers tend to hunt within their own
ethnic groups and so the few people that
did see who they thought was the Atlanta
Ripper he was like a very tall black man
with a wide brim pack no one ever really
gave a better description of him than
that and only two women saw him they
lived that lived wrong a lot of the
confusion comes about and even now I
think in all not so much now but at the
time like a grand jury actually came to
the conclusion that there was no Atlanta
Ripper that all of these women that got
killed over this you know three or four
year period we're all killed by
different people even though the MO in
most of the
was very similar yeah this would
actually make a really good movie or a
good it would and that's and like there
is one book about everyone that was
turning a blind eye to it because they
couldn't crack the case and yeah Derek
back in those days are like well so many
black people anyway so you know they
didn't look I mean there was a lot going
on he drew it didn't make the front page
of the Atlanta newspaper until the 8th
person was dead
like before that and then and actually
it's so um the early crimes in the
series if that's indeed what it was
we're so neglected that no one really
knows who this dudes first victim was ok
well this started the game let's start
with the very first crime scene okay
what happened well see like I said
they're not sure who the first victim
was all right most people like I've got
like a bunch of different um a bunch of
different sources but they all say
something different right about who the
first victim was because like I said the
the murders tended to end up in like
page 7 of the newspaper it was like just
two paragraph ago some woman got her
throat slashed who cares what kind of
thing probably somebody did it and we
don't care to it they didn't investigate
it and so they don't really know most
some sites say that the first victim was
rose at Rice and she was found on
January 22nd 1911 however I also
uncovered this other paper and it was
written in 2013 and it's by Vance
McLaughlin and Robert helping the third
now they had a list of 19 women that
were killed in Atlanta around this time
period now they took a bunch of the
victims out because the mo was the same
or because someone was convicted of
killing them even if the conviction was
questionable because there was some [ __ ]
later on with you know like police like
beating confessions out of suspects and
things of that nature
now they went with a very conservative
estimate
think eight women were definitely
Atlanta River the other one maybe maybe
not now they had the first victim being
Maggie Brooke or Maggie Brooks and she
was killed in October of 1910 however
when I was researching this for the book
there were actually two murders earlier
than that like one of them happened in
1909 like in spring of 1909 it was a
woman named Ella Reed and they found her
with her head bashed in and they found
her in a trash pile so that might have
been the same guy and then they found
another woman and I think and I believe
this was yeah this was later on in 1909
they found another victim in Peachtree
Creek and she had her throat slashed
now she was unidentified they never did
figure out who that was so there is a
lot of controversy about who was the
first victim and it'll probably all
happened in a high-crime areas anyway
well see that's what's not real clear
because like I said because the victims
were black they didn't really report on
them much right like I said it would be
in the back of the paper or no one
really because didn't make front page no
it's never good and and honestly in the
case of the Atlanta Ripper it didn't
make the front page until so many women
had been killed in a similar fashion
that they thought it was the same part
yeah the numbers piled up and then all
of a sudden look like a serial killer
but then later on the cops and the
courts going on a toss here okay let's
not say yeah that would mean that they'd
have to find the guy yeah and they
weren't gonna be they never did find it
yeah now they did arrest I mean at least
six arrests were made for various
murders but they could never really pin
it on anybody and now it's the same old
story no back in those days they're
beatin on these guys turn together cook
fast and they're not the right guy and
they think that definitely did happen it
was one run instance the problem was
like I said there was a run from between
about 1909 to about 1913 1914 there was
a huge spike in crime and it was always
like I said blacker mixture
women and they were not this wasn't like
a Jack the Ripper situation where
prostitutes they were all working women
they were used code observant very
usually coming home from work yeah you
know walking home they were maids in
people's houses and things like that and
they would just be walking home from
work minding their own business or
walking in with a grocery store
what-have-you and generally what would
happen and they think the the cases that
are generally attributed the Atlanta
River he had a very specific mo he would
come up to the women in the street
usually from behind and he would whack
him on the head with some with a blunt
instrument he would drag them because
you could usually see where they'd been
dragged me dragged him into some bushes
then he would usually either slash their
throat so severely that they were almost
beheaded or he would stab them like with
a straight razor in the throat or
something like that and in some cases he
would mutilate their body some way worse
than others he was taking people's
hearts out to some one woman had her
heart remote gaturro another weird thing
that he did um what's in some cases he
would cut the woman's shoes off weird
they don't really know why like
sometimes they would find the shoes
nearby but I got a foot fetish he's
trying to get to that but what I'm
thinking want to see it yeah
and but in some of the cases they never
did find the shoes but he always cut
them off yeah he wanted to see whether
they're whether or not they were
flat-footed I don't know yeah weird I
don't know what the hell Mike Eddie
Murphy flip fish okay I'm here yeah I
mean he must have had a foot fetish yeah
but yeah that was so and that that
didn't happen in every single case and
like I said that's why there's like a
lot of controversy about which which
victims could be attributed to him and
which ones were not okay so there were
there were two in 1909 that could have
been him okay and that was della Reid
and an unidentified woman they found in
Peachtree Creek now in 1910 there were
seven murders that I could discover
right now a lot of these were not
considered Ripper victims because a lot
of them were shot right there was um
there was a woman named Georgia Brown
there was a woman named Rosa rivers
these women were both shot now the thing
is they never solved their murders
now and there were some other you know
murders that were kind of more like a
Ripper style murder some of them didn't
have their throat slashed but some like
had their skull bashed in like with a
blunt instrument or something like that
and were dragged off the street this is
usually happened in a darkened Street or
darkened alley it's usually in the
evening because like I said it would
usually happen when the women were
coming home from work in the evening
like usually between 7:00 and 9:00 p.m.
why were there no witnesses there there
were a couple yeah I don't know it's
like it just seems I think it was like
women cutting through alleys and stuff
like that like on their way Ron it
seemed like row you know so so so the
police report they don't give a whole
lot of detail about the locations or
yeah not really like I said because I
think at the time the press was just
kind of like oh well it's just the black
neighborhood right and I will don't
worry about it so they got our women
they tell each other all the time you
know I mean because you have to make in
Atlanta at the time
Atlanta kind of like I mean this is less
than 50 years as a civil war is really
among as much as it lanta kind of liked
to put itself forward as kind of like
the you know basking of tolerance and
stuff and actually I'm you know
quote-unquote higher class black people
did have they owned businesses there and
said like there was like a lot of
booming in other of the protocol but
like a black Mecca right all about to go
right but the problem was even even so
it was only a very small percentage of
black people the city that had it good
everyone else there was still
segregation they couldn't eat in the
same restaurants they could drink that
they wanted on them you know they they
had a poll tax they've disenfranchising
them from voting and really only it had
only been in 1906 there was a huge race
riot where a white mob like kind of ran
through the city and killed at leads
like between 25 and 40 black men because
of some trumped-up kind of thing where
they thought they were raping white
women or some kind of [ __ ] like that but
newspapers made a big deal out of what
it didn't actually happen so you know
like I said when so when these women's
are turning up dead a lot of people just
thought oh well it's black men and you
know how they do like they get drunk on
Saturday night and they kill their
girlfriend
than that stretch so they're lumping up
that kind of accidental slash domestic
violence they're mixing that and what
cereal he would after I ate that to
cover oh sure yeah and yeah and they did
that even after a lot of people got
killed right like some people still had
that you know because like it like you
said I think they didn't want to admit
that they couldn't catch the guy of
course you know what I mean like I said
it wasn't the best environment you know
for this for this going on yeah whoever
was doing it of course is exploiting
that well yeah of course yeah they're
exploiting the chaos Anarchy right
bloating be the racial strike yeah oh
yeah big time so he knew he was doing
yeah and okay so like I said in 1910
there was a woman named Maggie Brooks
and she was a cook she was 23 most of
the victims were very young most were
very pretty
like I said Muslims of you know domestic
servants cooks that type of thing
the first earliest victims there are a
bunch that were shot and they're not
sure if that's the Ripper and then there
were some whose heads were just bashed
in or they would they were found at a
trash pile somewhere just with their
heads bashed in and their throats not
slashed they could have been the Ripper
maybe not they never did catch the
people that did that either but what was
unusual about the shootings is what just
a frequency of them in the location yeah
they think he did started off shooting
them and yeah I started off bettin and
bashing him and then he got into slash
and I'm like the river because it did
seem like there was an escalation a
little bit yeah I mean was to being it
seems like but yeah there's no way to
prove that probably it's the same guy
yeah turn it off with the easy way but
then it's not it's not satisfying enough
yeah you know shooting them is not going
to be it's not up close and personal
enough for this guy
yeah then he hits him with a rock and
fascism he's above but then that's not
good enough for him then he moves on to
sharp objects yeah
someone is bloody you know because
that's the thing I mean definitely
whoever this guy was he definitely had
the same issues as Jackie River um you
know and it should be said just like in
the Jack the Ripper case the women were
not raped but they were often you know
the way that they were stabbed in the
types of mutilations suggested that
some kind of twisted sexual woman who I
didn't have time so yeah time crazy she
just was just violent yeah but okay so
now in 1911 it seems like um that you
know there were a few in 1911 that were
shot but then when summer of 1911
started to started in about May and
there was a woman named Mary Belle
Walker and she was you know she was kind
of walking home from work or whatever
and she got killed and she had her
throat slashed and stuff like that brain
about it was only about a week or two
later there were two more victims Addie
watts and Lizzie Watson in relation and
these two it was right around this time
so right about the summer of 1911 that
the papers finally started to say oh
maybe this is the same guy during all of
these but it took that long because the
first crime were 1909 they sink like I
said they're not super sure but it was
summer of 1911 these three crimes that
happened like in the space of a month or
so and they were very similar with the
you know with the throat slashed and
everything like that also right around
in 1911 there were also some
complicating factors because there was a
woman named Lucinda McNeil and she was
killed only two weeks after rosa trice
was killed and she's some blogs there
are some you know things that I saw said
Rosa trice was the first victim but like
I said there were a bunch before that
two weeks after Rosa trice got killed
there was a woman named Lucinda McNeil
and she had her throat slashed with a
straight razor but the problem was that
a bunch of witnesses had seen her
husband killing her or had like followed
him you know after the murder or
whatever and found out that he did it
and he was actually convicted of that so
that kind of you know complicated
matters too because there were a couple
of it seems like generally in December
this one is the only one that it's
pretty certain that her
than did it right because a lot of
witnesses said you know we saw the them
fighting and we followed them and you
know we saw in him doing it being you
know so that kind of fed into the people
that wanted to say oh it's not a serial
killer
every single one of these women with no
health underwear so this incident help
undermine this case as a serial killer
case yeah yeah and so you know so like I
said there were a few of those like I
said this will listen to McNeal one like
I said I'm pretty sure that that's the
only one that they actually know that
the husband did it now a few of the
later crimes like husbands or boyfriends
were arrested or convicted and like that
but they could never really pin it on
them because most of the time the you
know the evidence was circumstantial and
they didn't really you know know if they
really did it or not they were just
trying to pin it on somebody or make it
look like it was all different people I
guess to keep you know to keep it from
being a panic or whatever but like I
said I kind of feel like there was a
serial killer it's just so weird that
it's you know in the case of Jack the
Ripper they know that was one dude at
least those five murders and maybe he
did other ones that but there's five
there sure it's the right guy
this one I've never seen so much
uncertainty about whether there was
actually a serial killer or not I think
there was yeah well and everything I've
read seems to come to that conclusion
like I said that the one paper from 2013
that I read they had the most
conservative estimate of the number of
victims but even then they still had
eight and that's three more than Jack
the Ripper Wow so that's still a bad
search even if you didn't kill 20 people
I mean eight that's still bad yeah
that's still more than Jack the Ripper
and Jack the Ripper's world famous and
the Atlanta Ripper is almost unknown
right which kind of evened out its
existence that's what I mean and that's
what I think that's what made this case
so interesting to me what I feel like
stumbled across it because one I was
amazed I'd never heard of it before
because I love true crime and I'm always
like reading about [ __ ] like that but
the fact that there's so much
controversy over you know how many of
these people were actually killed by
this person you know was there even a
serial killer for all these twenty
people killed by 20 different
perpetrators you know which in a way
censored
but I guess at the time they say kind of
maybe thought that and say well let's
take a break right now because it's
almost at the halfway part and then
we'll come back and talk a little bit
more about the Atlanta River we'll be
back in just a minute I'm learning
character Turkey German project
Entertainment Network Controller Rathlin
podcast they were thriving target on
large delicious and ammachi
super kick toe wrestling in the hot spot
we three interviews what they love until
me any superstars their stable it suits
a lot of works you can only hear them on
the project entertainment via like a
very much subculture corsets in clothing
is our favorite store for unusual
clothing shoes and accessories they
offer a wide selection of men's and
women's clothing at great prices so
culture also offers the cool selection
of shoes and accessories steampunk
gothic apparel retro corsets and so much
more at subculture corsets and clothing
checkout subculture online at subculture
corsets calm
that's subculture corsets calm make sure
you use the discount code 13 o'clock for
a 10% discount subculture corsets calm
or visit their store in Jacksonville
Florida just off i-95 project
Entertainment Network presents Buttercup
of doom with your host Kelly Owen just a
girl a girl who writes horror and
thriller fiction talks to bugs jumps and
puddles and now hosts a weekly podcast
full of opinions advice and a touch of
gypsy wisdom whether its current affairs
or social media nightmare join me as I
rant and rave and opera book big old
bucket of common sense
Wednesday I'm Buttercup of do
[Music]
[Music]
okay and we're back so we were talking
before about how it took until the you
know the summer of 1911 for them to
actually admit that maybe there was a
serial killer running around and it
actually made the front page of the
paper after one of the victims Addie
Watts got killed and that was that was
in June that was June 16th 1911 she was
found and the same thing happened to her
she had her throat slashed she of her
head bashed in and things like that and
they and plus they started to notice a
pattern it was like it usually happened
on the weekend Friday Saturday Sunday a
couple of them were Monday or Tuesday
but not usually and it was usually on a
weekend now here was kind of a break in
the case right July 1st 1911 there's a
woman named Emma Lou sharp and her
mother Lena sharp had gone to the
grocery store this was a Saturday night
Lena sharp had gone to the grocery store
and she'd been gone for more than an
hour I mean the market was just right
down the street so Emma Lou she got
worried because you know their deli
murders going on and she's like she
didn't know where her mother went so she
walks down to the market and the people
at the market saying she know she never
got here mom and Emma Lou was like
freaking out so she's like so she starts
going back home now on the way back home
this tall black man with a wide-brimmed
hat comes up to her in the street and he
says how are you feeling tonight or
something like that and she's like yeah
fine and then she tries to get around
him because he was kind of making her
nervous right and then he says to her
according to her don't be afraid I never
hurt girls like you and then he stabbed
her in the back Wow
and she's was during a daytime evening
this is evening do you talk to was drawn
not late evening but it was evening it
was probably what I think it was like 7
or 8 o'clock at night official was dark
yeah DJ's a Dora Krueger and you know
naturally she screamed and ran and a
bunch of neighbors heard her and came
out to help her and he ran off and he
ran off and and no ones are all she saw
she saw that he was a very tall like a
black guy with a wide-brimmed hat
and a long coat yeah that's like all she
remembered I mean as you would how you'd
imagine the river yeah so it's almost
like he seems like a phantom it's like
creepy when they said and and she said
that when he stabbed her he was like
laughing haha now she lived yeah however
after the stabbing they started looking
for her mother and they found her mother
dead released by Wow like only like a
block away and her head had been almost
cut off so so this poor woman had got
stabbed in the back by this guy and this
guy had probably killed her mother like
less than an hour before and and they
found her body off of the beaten trail
yeah right near there okay so someone
diverted her from going to the storm
well generally what would happen like I
said they think that he approached his
victims from behind and hit them over
the head and then dragged them somewhere
and then took him somewhere like not far
away yes so this poor woman man is like
that's the most horrible thing but
that's probably the most famous aspect
of the case of him saying you know don't
be afraid I never hurt girls like isn't
stabbing her now she just she did live
but her but her mother was not so lucky
this would have made it awesome nineteen
seventies like blaxploitation flick yes
like slasher yeah that time I'm
surprised like I said I'm surprised they
haven't made a movie about right but but
because it was a historical thing that
happened yeah there's not a whole lot of
details there you could fill in the
blanks make a really good slash of a
movie on some point yeah I mean because
yeah because like you said that it's
such a it's such a vague case and even
even the newspapers of the time because
I've read like a lot of the different
newspapers that catch like the different
newspapers said different [ __ ] right
because okay so the story I just told
you about Emma Lou sharp about getting
stabbed you back another newspaper I
think it was the Atlanta Constitution
another nice way for the same [ __ ]
city at the same time said that that is
the dot wasn't how that went
they said that Emma Lou and her mom were
walking to the store together right and
they both got jumped on by this guy he
like killed a mom and then she stabbed
and every boy screaming that was that
girl but and she got away but most of
the other sources I read said no she
went looking for her mother
later and then met the guy but you know
so that [ __ ] happened and then there was
another woman allegedly now she didn't
she didn't get hurt but she thinks she
might have seen him now this was about a
week later it was it was a following
Saturday night it was July 8th 1900 and
there was a girl named Mary yelled Elle
and she was 22 and she was she was a
cook also and she left the house where
she worked and she was walking through
and walking past an alley and she heard
someone whistle and she stopped and
looked because she thought someone was
trying to get her attention and she saw
the same thing she saw a very tall black
man in a hat she could really see his
face that because he was in the alley
and he was running at her
she said he had a quote/unquote cat-like
tread yeah so almost like this was like
spring-heeled jack well he must have
been pretty young yeah I would guess so
so he like runs to warn her so she
screams and she runs back to the house
where she worked and told her boss hey
but the Ripper is out here right and the
guy comes out with his gun and ran to
the alley and the guy was still standing
there but he was like in the shadows
right so the guy that she worked for WM
Seltzer was his name he told the guy put
your hands up or whatever and the guy
just took off down the alley Wow
and because like I said he couldn't
shine like this would have made a good
movie I mean I don't know why not
everybody should have did it back in
1970 yeah you know actually instead of
making candy man I should have made this
movie
well what yeah but Candyman was a good
movie that was I saw Tom kind of Mitch
kind of picture in it yeah I mean yeah
kind of like sound like a Jack Tripper
story kinda like Candyman yeah I was
like if somebody made this into a movie
it would be like Candyman like mixed
with from hell yeah like with I don't
know something else yeah I'm surprised
no one's actually made this intro and
like I said I'm surprised that it's not
better known right because some of these
crimes are pretty horrible I mean they
were they were pretty similar to how to
detect the Ripper type victims I mean
one of them had
cut out when shoes is involved and stuff
like that and he killed more people than
Jack the Ripper did right and they never
caught him never caught so I so you know
for some reason it's just a not elite
way there you could make a legendary
kind of a villain character based on
that yeah it's pretty neat I know that's
what I mean I you know we're doubting
whether or not he even existed yeah so
it's almost like there's almost like
that manners my anthem as weii quality
yeah
he ran like a cat I thought she said
yeah but uh doesn't I mean it's like
it's on it like he's fast and silent
yeah moving with power yeah so she
didn't get killed even though clearly
this marielle girl she was clearly
intended as an expecting because he did
come running at her yeah but she didn't
get killed she was fine and you know
other than psychological drama but um so
that was the first thing that broke this
kind of streak because for a while
someone got killed every Saturday night
like a woman got killed they were all
women there were no male victims and
they're all about the same age well I
think the oldest one was 40 that they
think was him so no one got killed that
Saturday night because she got away
however on the Tuesday morning which was
July 11th a bunch of workers were coming
to work on a sewer like at this
intersection and they see a puddle of
blood in the road and they and with a
trail and they follow the trail and in a
gully nearby they find a body and the
girl's name was Sadie Holley she was she
worked at a laundry her head had been
almost cut off and she also had her
shoes cut off they didn't find her shoes
they did find she had like two combs in
her hair that she'd been wearing and
they found one on one side of the road
and one on the other side of the road
birkoff yes the comb she had her hair so
I don't know if he just like hit her and
they went flying or I did have a foot
fetish Jenni you've taken the chute yeah
he didn't do it in every case but in a
couple end of view of the case you want
her shoes yeah for some reason and he
cut them off he didn't like take them
off here's the thing about the murder of
Sadie Holley and this probably goes to
demonstrate you know the the panic that
was setting it in the community you know
because
black community was starting to flip out
because they said you know no one's
doing anything about it
they returned like all the churches in
the area we're trying to raise money for
rewards they were trying to encourage
the police to put on some black
detectives right yeah you know because
you know the way the white guys weren't
becoming down in the end it's you know
so they couldn't really effectively
patrol the area they and like I said
they didn't really beef up any patrols
until you know all of these other
murders was taking place like I said it
was like the eighth or ninth victim at
this point and like I said it's there's
some confusion too about what's this the
seventh victim was it the ninth victim
don't know now Sadie Holley it turned
out that the day after she her body was
found which was the Tuesday they
arrested a guy named Henry huff now the
reason they arrested him was because was
and the only reason they arrested him
was because somebody said that they had
seen him with Sadie Holley on Monday
night and that they had been arguing I
think it was a cab driver and that was
the only that was the only reason they
said they put in the top said they
picked him up and he had a scratch on
his arm or something like that
and his pants were dirty or you know who
knows it was something like that
so he was a 27 year old guy here's the
thing they held him on suspicion but
they even they knew they didn't have
enough evidence to convict him right and
it seems like even the press were
getting annoyed and I'm sure like the
press feels like printed like really
racist [ __ ] all the time because that
was just a matter of course right back
then but even then if this kills me I
read this on a different blog about this
but it's that even at the time like one
day when they printed something that a
black person said yeah they printed it
like in in that kind of day to make it
sound like phonetic like yeah right and
stuff like that and I was like oh my god
yeah and over they today they wrote it
out in device yeah I try old-fashioned
Teavana right so yeah even in that case
the newspapers were still we don't think
that guy was the killer
all right like whit and even the
newspapers like didn't think the police
were doing that
job so they arrested this guy they held
a month suspicion you know the papers
were like whatever and that's probably
not him
there was also they also arrested
another guy named Todd Henderson he was
um at a bar they picked him up in
Decatur Street now another witness said
that they had seen Henderson with Sadie
Holley the woman who got murdered and
that he had seen them like at a
drugstore like the day before she got
killed or something like that now in the
case of Todd Henderson they brought in
Emmylou Sharpe the girl that had been
stabbed in the back to see if she could
identify him one newspaper said that
when she heard his voice because she
heard him talking to her that she shrank
back and she was afraid she's like yeah
that's him I think that's him however
another newspaper reported that she
wasn't sure that it was him so nobody
knows if she identified Todd Henderson
as the guy that had stabbed her because
one newspaper said one thing and another
newspaper said oh I don't know if that's
him you know what I mean could they
place him at the scene if it's a no
there were some other things that might
have been like I think he said I think
Todd Henderson was the guy that said oh
I don't have a straight razor or
anything like that but then somebody
said oh he dropped off a straight razor
to be sharpened at the barber shop or
whatever there was not enough evidence
to convict him either so even her arrest
him really I mean he was held on
suspicion and the problem too was that
while these guys there was another guy
that I think his name was Daniel or
something like that that was his last
name they kind of held him on suspicion
too but the problem is while these three
guys were like being held on suspicion
and under were being investigated there
were more murders right so murders were
taking place yes so so it's like to the
head the wrong guys yeah so it's like
either they I mean and the thing about
Henri Hoff is that they only held him on
suspicion for Sadie Hollies murder they
didn't held him on suspicion for being
the river what they thought maybe he
just killed her and that was it
and then they didn't even have enough
evidence to sit on my pin it on him for
that you know so the thing is who
[ __ ] knows I don't know but they had
so they had like all these they had all
these rewards all this other stuff and
nothing was helping their there was also
and I think I mentioned this a little
bit before the city recorder who was a
local magistrate in Atlanta now he was
of the he was of the belief that every
single one of these murders was a
different person so he did not believe
that there was any serial killer okay
and he kind of came out and said because
well people were like well yeah but
there's patterns like they're done the
same way and there's like they all
happened on Saturday night and also chef
and he said oh it's because Saturday
night is the black man big night like he
gets tanked up and then decided to gonna
kill a woman because you know cuz she's
been unfaithful or she's mouthing off or
something like that it was a gathering
for a lot of good I said yeah he's too
big off the movies I know it really
would I don't know why they don't why
the testicle they said that's that's his
big night so he just so all these
different people and then they're just
like using this serial killer thing like
just to blame it on yeah you know what I
mean not helping the case was also you
know the one of the one of the the guys
that was arrested for the crimes I
believe it was Tom Henderson you know
they were at questioning about the
Ripper murders and he said you know if I
was the Ripper I was started with my
wife because she's given me so much
trouble to root that's not how they
printed the paper they printed it like
like he says like stupid you know
phonics or whatever but that's what he
said and yeah so this guy this match
Royals person the city recorder that
said this about them getting tanked up
and stuff like that
he actually said quote there are at
least a thousand Negro men in Atlanta
today who stand ready to cut the throats
of their wives at the slightest
provocation yeah he said that in the
paper quote unquote
yeah so yeah so he thought that there
was no Sheree o killer okay so however
like I said while these three men were
under investigation or whatever
there was another murder August 31st and
this was a Marion Duncan she was found
west of Atlanta on some railroad tracks
and her throat had been cut from ear to
ear then there was another murder as
well
Minnie wise and this happened uh in
November oh there was also there was one
called
Eva Florence too but they're not sure if
that was a ripper murder but the one day
mini wise they found her in November and
she had have her shoes removed and her
throat was cut and also the index finger
on her right hand was cut off at the
joint like just her finger they took it
I don't know why at this point most had
a ring on it
maybe yeah I mean they you know I don't
I'm sure no one ever thought robbery was
about it because these were all for
woman but yeah well maybe she had that
trophy yeah true that was the only one
where a finger was taken though like
there were other mutilations on some of
the other bodies but that was only one
with the finger was taken now the thing
about many wives though is that later on
her husband bud was arrested for the
murder and so it's almost kind of like
you know Biddy killer and make it look
like a Ripper murder because there could
have been copycat all right - and you
know that's another possibility then let
me ask you this these murders was this a
spike in homicide it does appear that it
was it was not the normal baseline right
okay according to I mean according to
everything I read like I said since
crimes where blacks were the victims
yeah um we're not generally investigated
very well or weren't really recorded on
very much fruit you know they're not
entirely certain but it does seem like
from 1909 to 1914 there was this huge
spike and all the victims were of a
similar you know were to Azul women aged
women you know and they were found in
similar situations I'm pretty sure it's
a suit it does really sound like a serum
and like I said even if even if the most
conservative estimates turn out to be
true he killed at least eight women at
least right and it was probably more
like shading more towards
Wow and like I said this is why I killed
me that there's not and it also kills me
that they thought that maybe that there
wasn't a serial killer that for example
okay so the mayor's office at this point
like I said now after many wives got
killed and like I said they say maybe
maybe it was her husband they don't know
but they sent out a letter like the the
police department was really embarrassed
and stuff because the Atlanta Ripper
story went national at this point you
know a lot of the papers were saying
what's the matter with the Atlanta
Police they can't catch this guy bla bla
and then a week after that it went
national and the Atlanta Police were
trying to like kind of save face going
hey big cities have these kind of things
and we're trying and all this other kind
of stuff then the this was the worst
murder this is kind of like like I said
it's a ramping up just like Jack the
Ripper you know Jack the Ripper his last
victim she got totally dissing bailed
she was just all cut up and she was all
[ __ ] up and this was the same thing
that happened here this time this
happened on November in November 23rd
and her head was almost cut off and her
chest was cut open and her heart was
pulled out and put next to her right
that that's Mary Putnam and I think she
was also the oldest like I think she was
40 at this point like after this which
was probably the the grossest of the
murder scenes some of the police and
some of the police detective started
blaming the black community saying you
guys aren't doing enough so weird to
catch this guy you know because like I
said the cops were just they they
obviously couldn't catch anybody so then
they were starting to blame the victims
essentially saying why don't you guys do
something to catch them that's obviously
they're not doing that much of a good
job but so okay so the summer of 1911
that was kind of the summer and fall of
1911 that was kind of the worst but
there were a few after that they found a
few more in 1912 a couple of these like
Ida Ferguson she was found in early 1912
and they think maybe that was her
boyfriend now her boyfriend was
convicted
he Elliott he was convicted of that but
the evidence a kind of circumstantial
same deal with Pearl Williams who was
found on January 19th
she also her they also convicted
somebody for that it was a guy who
apparently was in love with her and said
you know if I can't marry no one well a
lot allegedly so they're not sure but
she was found the same way so it slashed
all that kind of stuff so I'm kind of
suspecting that she's probably a ripper
victim also so they probably put a
couple in is it guys behind bars right
yeah no what happened to the murders do
they eventually just kind of heat around
yeah what ended up happening that was
one in February 1912 which was Alex e
Owens now her husband Charlie Ellen's
was convicted of that although like I
said they think maybe the confession was
beaten out of him so but he went to jail
regardless now there were two more in
April 1912 and in May 1912
neither of these women was ever
identified and one of them was a 15 year
old girl they found her floating in a
creek like her throat had been slashed
and someone it's Runner the nobody came
forward saying that's my daughter and
it's weird because several of these were
not there were actually I think there
were three four I think there were four
that were unidentified women yeah one of
the ones one of the last ones was was a
15 year old girl and they found her in
the Chattahoochee River but doesn't it's
not there's no definite link with those
last two ones those last two they will
the mo was similar their throats were
about in animal fashion yeah and it was
right around the same time period to me
it sounds like there was a serial killer
it does definitely oh my gosh the cops
couldn't catch the guy yeah they didn't
want to admit they couldn't catch this
guy though that's what I mean so they
did some people in jail
oh now okay the guy that was beaten the
confession was beaten Adam that was
actually a man named Brown and he went
to trial for killing Eva Florence who
was found in October 1911 so he got
acquitted though okay so the last one
they think like I said a 19 year old
girl in May 1912 and they think that was
the last one there was another one in
March 1913 a girl named Laura Smith and
she was a servant also young
race girl and she was a servant and they
found her dead now they think maybe that
was the last one was Laura Smith and
that was 1913 which maybe with four
years after the first one if they indeed
the third in 1909 now here's what's
weird though
in 1914 firefighters started finding
these little notes like pinned around
the city purporting to be from the
Atlanta River and all the notes said I'm
going to cut the throats of all Negro
women who are out on the streets after a
certain time so they don't know so much
like Jack the Ripper
you know taunting the police and stuff
like that they don't know if the actual
killer left these notes or was a copy or
if it was a copycat or a prank or who
knows because what ended up happening
was that someone would leave the note
and then someone would call in an alarm
at a fire box okay and then the
firefighters would go to the fire box
and find that note there right so they
don't know if it was just a prank right
sounds like a prank but yeah it's a
pretty city it's pretty sick right but
you know but like I said they don't
really know if the Jack the Ripper
letters were really from the person
killing them although he did send them
that kidney didn't ya
so yeah a lot of each one was at least
one now and after that like so the
murders they think stopped in 1913 and
then there were the note like a year
after that and then when the notes
appeared there weren't any murders were
there no yeah I don't think I don't
think yeah I know I kind of feel like
that probably wasn't the killer because
the thing is even though nowadays the
murders are you know largely forgotten
about they said actually the murders
were big news for a couple of years
after that you know what I mean like
they kept referring back to and things
like that but for some reason I bet you
moved out of the area maybe he did and
like I said I think they made a total of
six arrests and they I don't even think
they arrest anybody for being the Ripper
they would just arrest a person for one
murder right and then I think only one
was convicted and it was just a
conviction of one murder to somebody
song or whatever and I don't think that
any idea had any idea who this dude was
and I don't even think they ever had him
in custody I don't even think those guys
at the end got to do I don't even think
it was that right so it's just kind of a
case where
like I said people are just like still
fascinated with Jackson represent ever
constant like that but this guy yeah
killed way more people than Jack the
Ripper in just his horrible fashion yeah
and it's like forgotten about I think he
thought you were Jack arute I kind of
feel like that too because you have to
think I mean the Jack the Ripper murders
that wasn't that long ago I mean you
know it happened if it if it certain
1909 that was just you know when the
jacket performers were 1888 right let me
give you inspired by Jack and that's
when you might have been I think yeah I
think he was saw himself as like living
high on the hog why go after hookers
when you can go after good girls yeah
yeah because he definitely did Shannon
her standards were higher yeah yeah
trying to be more uh what's a good way
to put it more daring you know yeah
attacking like respectable excellent
working women more rather than yeah
maybe he did maybe a little ourselves
yeah I would be I'd be kind of
fascinated to see what this guy's
psychology was though cuz it's just
seemed like and I mean if the woman if
the woman that got stabbed in the back
Emily sharp I mean if that was him which
imagining it was because why would some
random dude just come from savvy but you
know for him to just stab her and laugh
and he didn't really seem to be worried
about getting caught or anything I was
just like in the middle of the street
here just going to the market kind like
a kamikaze style attack and he probably
the time you did praise and care whether
I get caught per se yeah it was just a
thrill kill and he makes it even he
escapes and it was man that's close yeah
maybe like you said he's got off on the
thrill because I mean Jack the Ripper
kind of did the same right where he
would just kill people and write a
Sharif mini simmer down for a few weeks
then you go out and get an element ya
know some kind of hatred towards women
it must have been because yeah hatred
towards good girls yeah I guess so cause
like I said I'll you know all the
victims were you know pretty young girls
all worthless servants cooks things like
that laundry women just walking home
from work mind anyone I Ted Bundy kind
of said the same thing that day that he
had high standards that he went after
college girls you know who were pretty
didn't do anything wrong as you know
that he said that the guys came after
hookers they were bottom feeders seen up
cowards yeah that's the way he could
yeah I guess that's the same because I
serial killers do tend to go after
prostitutes and yes girls absolutely
just because I I guess they feel like
it'll be easier for them not to go hot
one says they'll go with you and you
don't have to anything really and plus
10t money call them bottom feeders yeah
there cuz it did that didn't have any
mojo they were weak man yeah yeah I
don't get ya serial killer psychology
it's fascinating but it's also like
really disturbing tonight and this guy
like I said they know so little about
this guy and they don't even know how
many people he killed they don't know
why they don't know why I started it out
you know what I mean and so you go yeah
II go into I don't know I just I just
found this a really fascinating case and
the both fascinating thing about it was
that I hadn't heard of it before I'm huh
you know what I mean and I'm kind of and
I'm into serial killers and true crimes
and stuff like that I just kind of came
across it accidentally and I'm like how
I don't why don't more people know about
this case that's crazy kinda like an
arrow Flynn style guy comes running in
Nike in the back and then split kind of
a fan of the opera style that's kind of
what I was thinking I was thinking like
a fan of the Opera looking guy yeah yeah
creepy yes we can wrap it up yes okay
this was saying how this was a very
disturbing episode fun an interesting
show I hope you guys enjoyed it and like
I said if you enjoyed it it's going to
be in my new book which will probably be
out before October which is called the
faceless villain and it's about unsolved
like creepy unsolved murders in the 20th
century the first volume is going to be
1902 1960 so this is going to be an
attack metal and all that good stuff and
let's see once again shout out to
project Entertainment Network you guys
are doing a great job over there and
thank you very much for the spike in our
listenership which had really came with
the Ed Warren show which I guess you
guys really liked we'll do some more
yeah we'll have to do another haunting
episode yeah we're definitely going for
Devin you know there's a lot of Botto
maater
yeah we're definitely good doing on
those and also my book fiancée and hand
is out if you're into a poltergeist
paranormal type stuff go check that out
and leave me a review if you like it
could be a best-seller
very much yes it is I've already sold a
lot of copies to thank you everybody
that bought one of those and that'll do
it for this week's episode we will see
you next Tuesday
bye
[Music]
[Music]